moi je serais pas de faire oublier tout
est propre béatrice picard vous venez
d'avoir 91 ans et encore une fois
aujourd'hui vous vous rendez au travail
pour enregistrer la voix de mort si nous
sommes seuls à 30/1 amis que vous
incarnez c'est cette voie là oui c'est
ça c'est incroyable on part en vacances
à bostens à trentels fars j'ai réussi à
placer ma boîte de sorte que quand les
gens bien oui vous faites partie des
week-ends à sa rage de vaincre autant de
voix si vous saviez automatiquement
maintenant l'on se place la voie et je
peux parler comme ça longtemps et il
s'annonce amabile pu la voir mais il
faut que je raconte comment s'était
passé avec les as tu pu donc vous pouvez
proposer donné mardi d'un instant à
l'autre
oui mais les rats devenir béatrice
j'étais absolument fasciné en faisant
votre biographie avec l'argent peut tout
dire en résumé votre vie ressemble à un
immense tourbillon ce que c'est comme ça
aussi que vous la voyez
oui parce que je vais pas fait beaucoup
mais comme un tourbillon
moi je suis dans l'ensemble ce
tourbillon c'est ça tombe dans l'eau
mais on m'envoie en vigeur desservir
tourbillon iton parce que je suis cancer
cancer
on a des auffes antastique que pierre
débauche si aussi fantastique que les
l'apogée qu'on peut avoir eu alors donc
moi je les imagine toujours quand je
suis rendu très basse je me suis dit ah
c'est au fonds d'appui sienne je donne
un coup de talon et géra monte au cours
de votre carrière de 65 ans vous avez
joué dans 150 production théâtrale dans
une soixantaine de télérama avec toute
votre expérience
comment vous voyez aujourd'hui le métier
de comédien on voit on va accepter les
pots vides parce que le métier de
comédienne je trouve que c'est le plus
beau métier pour moi si ça c'est un
enrichissement à chaque fois
de pouvoir travailler un personnage de
pouvoir tomber en amour avec son
personnage
et puis une fois qu'on ait personnages
bien ancrée en soit on va l'offrir au
public et c'est là qu'il ya cette
communion entre le public et la terre
qui fait que pour moi le sait on n'a
plus rien d'un vent tourne à kkr soit
puis le public ne nous nous le rend bien
d'ailleurs de rencontrer celle qui a
enlevé challans harry à ses amis
en coulisses on dit que vous êtes une
super woman parce que vous avez élevé
quatre enfants tout en enchaînant les
rôles les uns après les autres
travaillent 7 jours sur 7
j'ai l'impression que pour béatrice
picard il ya 26 ans donc il ya quand
même 24 heures dans un bureau
mais c'est parce que je perds des pommes
mois de temps à dormir invitant par
nuitée comme les gens disent ou font
dormir ce lampe est et c'est là que je
me rends compte que je dis pas ce que je
dois en huit heures des fois neuf mais
je récupère et je dormais 5h à peu près
par neil et je récupérerai à coups de 5
minutes 4 minutes celui à l'époque on
avait une carte on travaille les gens de
coffee break maintenant on utilise la
pause c'est bravo pour le français mais
pendant cette pause lors qui durait dix
minutes
moi j'allais m'asseoir sur une chaise et
je dormais pas piller la tête et je
monte en mai et j'ai tord mais il se
faisait comme ça à coups de 5 minutes 10
minutes le récupérer je récupérerai et
donc vous en dire plus besoin de dormir
pendant éclatant j'essayais de me lever
avant que les enfants se lèvent pour
aller faire du lavage perdait des choses
et c'est même s'il y avait quelqu'un qui
venait m'aider ou six pour pour les
enfants parce que la personne avait à
cette date m
mal en pis car on doit cesser parce que
vous devez aller travailler au
centre-ville de montréal pour mais vous
avez d'autres projets ont travaillé avec
antonine maillet sur un sous l'eau oui
oui ça va s'appeler antonine et perfecta
c'est l'histoire d'une histoire de de
madame perfecta c était sa femme de
ménage qui était une espagnole qui a
connu la guerre d'espagne et tout ça et
qui viennent ici au canada
je raconterai pas tout parce qu'on va
pouvoir le vivre sur scène ce n'est pas
juste une histoire à raconter mais il va
y avoir du vécu ça c'est le mouvement
mon cheval de bataille pour mais jusqu'à
mai dernier jusqu'à mais sans en tête
parce que j'ai toujours dit moi je veux
jouer au théâtre
si tu me traites vie jusqu'à son temps
après ce peut-être que je penserais je
pense pas à la retraite peut-être né à
moins que d'autres projets viennent
béatrice picard quelle belle rencontre
merci merci beaucoup faire si déjà ils
votre âge j'avais jamais eu lien qu au
grain
ah oui ok c'est bon vous allez manquer
votre tour bus